at rich Calif everybody everyone here
know rich guy needs a man who needs to
know it is good and weird to be back
yeah it's weird to have you here it's
really gonna bring it over here kind of
your fault I'm sitting in this chair so
you want me to tell the story do you
want to tell us you go from so for
people who don't know Alexander Zoe
probably don't know Alexander Bruce
everyone who knew Peter MacKay chamber
and zoe quinn the most popular person on
the internet so the story is once upon a
time I used to sit in this chair my
bicester well that chair that guy was my
boss but these guys were I was part of
their crew I got Chris his job yeah he
went to college with my wife I resume to
rich any time a posting was on games
please guys and after us a seven-year
absence I think you guys have finally
maybe gotten here okay okay you guys is
awesome this I never would imagine that
you guys would get this is you have a
gorgeous set you have great shows you
have great rapport with a gorgeous
photograph upset yeah I've seen the set
that like my desk was behind that
portrait yeah we have to rip out the old
on the spot thing I'm sorry but where is
it do it I don't know tambien
Giancarlo's almost everything else
you're probably wondering why I
assembled this motley crew of random
game developers and I have interesting
chats with you guys at GDC and whenever
we talk it's always great to pick your
brain about the reasons why you're doing
what you're doing based on like your
personal lives so I had an interesting
chat with you Alex about you release the
antechamber you've been working on it
for 12 decades eventually got it out and
now are you out of love with indeed do
you want to go into mainstream game
development or was this all just like a
reason to get out of Australia and I
mean that in like I know you want to get
out of Australia
it's complicated i mean i didn't even
know if I want to get out of side of
Australia now you know I blank testing
the waters in a whole lot of different
ways I didn't get into making
antechamber because i was like i love
you know indie games i have to be in
india and the vet you know game
developer i was playing games all of my
life i was starting to get a bit over
what a lot of mainstream things were
doing sorry Bethesda who was just on
starting to get a bit over things and so
I went into University didn't know what
I was doing gave myself a lot of options
fell into game development fell into
independent game development and just
had to spend several years you know
working on that because everything was
all really circumstantial and after that
process was finished I didn't really
know what to do with myself and it's a
bit complicated you know emotions are
complicated but you know I just took
some time to step away from things think
about you know what I want to be doing
moving forwards so I'm still trying to
figure that out because you've been sort
of enjoying your time after antechamber
doing a lot of sort of touring coming to
events like this even though you're not
necessarily showing anything off like
what is it about indie development that
it may be pushing you away or is it just
you've creative things you want to do to
darnton but that can't be done with that
are you sick of it it's not really
things about independent development
about pushing me away it's that I spent
basically 26 years only caring about
work like my whole world was just about
work I made this game things ran you
know great and you know the process was
just so rough on me emotionally that I
was like I've had this big success and
now I don't know what to do with myself
and you know I'm trying to people very
adverse to change yeah you move house
you start a job you lose a job it's
difficult to deal with I basically had
to say at 26 years was one set of
problems now absolutely none of that
matters here's a completely new set of
problems that you have to deal with go
yeah and that's and that's quite
difficult and so some of me wanting to
step away was just getting away from
that a bit arriving about some other
things speaking of emotion Zoey
obviously working on it's not okay Cupid
most people would know you from
depression quest which you created last
year and I didn't get to go but I heard
your panel the Patrick yesterday was
anyone here at that one
what is it about because your work
especially over the past year has
basically it's been so maybe not
detrimental but it's impacted your
personal life so much what is it about
making games that why are you still
doing this if it's so negatively
affecting you and so many other
different ways why am I still doing this
I mean honestly I still feel like I I
came from all these different places in
creativity before ending up in games and
it's like the one thing that's been able
to hold my attention for this long being
able to combine all these different
things into one really cohesive specific
statement is I don't know another way to
do that and beyond that I feel like it's
just such a powerful medium in such an
exciting time to be here there's so many
different things happening and there's
like you can have real impact as an
indie game developer right now maybe
what happens in the future like being
able to come to things like this and
talk to people and talk to people who
maybe didn't know that they could be a
game developer yet and just need to hear
somebody tell them that they can do it
right being able to do that is such an
amazing thing and I am not sure what I
could what is more valuable than that
that I can be doing with my time and
with the amount of visibility that I
have suddenly out of nowhere yeah I mean
I believe I've only really been doing
this for two years to but I've loved
video games but like my entire life I'm
actually working on a weird silly thing
now to sort of decompress instead of
focusing on this on okcupid is it a
reality TV show but indeed no um have
you seen the movie the room yes I may be
talking with one of the cast members
about doing an F mvgame is it tommy was
oh I don't want some of those because I
want it don't you audit okay but I I
sort of want to be able to do something
goofy and ridiculous and especially cuz
like it's an indie rite of passage to
like be with a nostalgic game of your
childhood but my first my first console
was a 3d oh okay my first console game
was night trap so it's my turn the video
games industry is tearing you apart Lisa
Cara Mia but I got it so when you look
at these two young whippersnappers and
you as an elderly man who have more gray
hair than me my favorite yeah but not on
my eyebrows oh it's
well that happened I was like twelve and
was going that was the Horcrux that was
yep and so when I you know they're young
successful enjoying it in the creative
you know part of their life you're jaded
and tired I'm not jaded I'm just rot Roo
trying to rise on you right now go ahead
but you've got like you've got a family
you've got a kid like how much does that
influence the type of work that you do
we're gonna from the prices of
development you obviously had you know
when 30 HR damn that was must have been
really dramatic and then you had summer
camp yes how much of what you do
creatively is impacted by your your
responsibilities as a all of it right
now and not only impacts what I do
creative but also how I treat my
co-workers so right now I'm executive
producer at disruptor beam we have Game
of Thrones Game game phones the Senate
will you announce our new game of sweet
star chick timelines very exciting stuff
with [ __ ] thank you I have to say
otherwise i would let me come here no
but basically so I have a wife I have a
kid that's why we moved back to the east
coast with so my wife go to law school
and pursue her career the chair was
starting to fall apart again spot so I
know and now that I have that and now
that I'm in a position in my career
where I help determine how other people
should be spending their time at work
like I know I want to spend I love my
job and I'll do my gel whole time but it
also i love my son and I love my wife on
us seen as much as possible so I'm in a
position to make sure that I get to do
that but then I also ensure that all my
co-workers to get to do that as well
like so I'm 35 now and from 22 to 32 it
was I was probably felt like i was
working 12-hour days is that fair Ryan
we were doing some of that yeah 60 yeah
but and that was awesome because I loved
it because that's all I wanted to do but
now it's like hey you know what's really
nice hammocks and if I want to spend
time on that hammock I can but I also
want to make sure that everyone works
around we can also get some good hammock
time and also make a great game like
even though the scent do you think
that's why there is the the tends not to
be obviously those John Baum guys are
weird but the tends not to be that many
older game journalists like Jeff is
going to be doing ounces entire life
right yeah like yourself
Ryan Ekberg like so my why I game
journalist anymore is because because if
I had to move geographically and would
you still be doing it uh maybe it's it's
so much more fun to make something
yourself than to talk about someone
else's stuff like there's definitely
some joy out of making quote it's true
like making the show is awesome but like
in having those shows like we got to
make a cartoon actually based on my trap
that you should watch my god it's called
time trotters it's amazing excellent so
but making that show was more fun than
doing interviews like you get to meet
all kinds of great people here and you
get to get to like a taste of that
creativity but like for every person
who's on a couch from a studio there's
another there's hundreds more people
they're just as talented and just as
awesome like making some small part of
the game and to be able to be around
those people all the time and be able to
just help them do their job it's just
it's awesome also it's really nice
having a deadline that isn't today right
like what we doing today okay what does
it do all right today all right good all
right now it's Tuesday what's up through
it again that's what the schedule is a
king swapping videos like wait we have
months or years we have years so I all
the stuff we can do yeah so you you work
in big teams alexander you were
essentially working on your own for that
long period of time that's the story do
you feel even just even in your own
space you were like i was working last
later they did have other people like in
our standing in the Netherlands but i
did the most of you so do you feel like
if you were to do another project
whatever that may be in games are not
that you'd prefer to do it with other
people was that did that take a toll it
definitely took a toll I mean like the
circumstances that I mean now very
different to what I was going through
when I was making antechamber and I mean
like I know a hell of a lot more
talented people now than I did Ben and
so if I was starting up a new project it
would be much easier to get people on
board with with my ideas and it was when
I was just some random student trying to
convince other students why they should
work with me instead of going drink beer
yeah am and Zoey you you tend to work on
really small projects that take like a
couple of months you kind of work on
them get the matter working then get
them out you've got a long list of games
that are that are added
it's not something you like doing more
so like stuff that you could kind of
spend a couple of months on rather than
spending like your general like two or
three years development well it's tricky
I've been working on Snyder take you but
for two years actually and it's like oh
really yeah on and off yeah depression I
wasn't i expected five people to play
depression quest for people think i was
insane and one person would be like okay
so that was totally not something I
expected at all I do like shorter dab
cycles because I especially because I'm
so new at this I learned things really
quickly like I'm still figuring out what
my voice is and I'm so ridiculously
burnt out yeah like after two years and
which is one of the reasons I'm taking a
step away and doing something less
serious for a little while that's why
you're working on a new game ya heard
that it's it's just it's I'm also
worried about getting to that trap or
you just keep making new things and i
actually am finishing with it um so I do
kind of want to shift into something
where I'm at least working with other
people partially to make sure a I don't
get designer itís and do that constantly
and be because it's really kind of
miserable working alone in the way that
I have them I need someone to because
you like can't unknow focus really hard
and like you sort of like are chasing
your NT land changing things that don't
need to be changed and it's good to have
someone that I feel like you're being
stupid stop doing that so I'm hopefully
going to start doing different stuff in
terms of that awesome idea I think the
sooner that you you you can again be
recognized for the games and because
you've got an interesting alternative
persona now or like responsibility with
depression quest that sort of does that
get too much maybe sometimes where
you've become this kind of voice for
this community it's it's definitely a
lot more than I ever anticipated like
again I thought no one would play it and
as I feel like there is sort of i do
have a responsibility take it very
seriously i'm working through backlogs
of months of emails of people that have
reached out because it's i know it's how
hard it is to reach out to somebody and
when somebody tell it starts off an
email if I've never told anybody this
before I feel like that can't be
responded to it silence yeah and or and
I know that I'm probably running myself
ragged doing that but it's
really important to me so it's worth it
and yeah it's like I feel so so bad
sometimes too because people come to be
looking for answers it's like I'm not a
therapist I'm just a game developer but
yeah let's let's talk and I mean it's
just it's such a weird thing I never I
never thought I'd be in any sort of
position to do this especially because I
mean video game yeah but much respect
for doing it in for tackling it I'm
actually responding to those emails
because a lot of other people wouldn't
do it and before I let you guys go I
want to ask because this is packed and
because you are all involved in game
development and so many of you champion
other games and what is the one game on
the show floor that you think stands out
Alexander first of all mushroom 11
obviously you guys saw me at the booth
and lake if I forced you to play that
game and we're forcing everyone it
working because it's amazing and you
should all go play that game you should
work in PR and get rich i'll pick tower
of guns okay yeah yeah made by a good
friend of mine for 38 studios joe
mirabelle oh he's an environment artist
who made this rogue like basically a
tribute to doom first-person shooter
that if you like such things you should
play it it's on the floor there's a lot
of wrongs and guns lots of bullets lots
of money hops yeah straight circle
strafing yeah Oh car again just like
Wolfenstein accepted at the Nazis exact
and Zoe what do you think I'm gonna be
horrific Lee biased and go with framed
because it's doing a lot of interesting
stuff with nonlinear storytelling and
it's I also a major SAP foreign war
stories and it's got a really beautiful
art style I'm curious to see what that
ends up being at the end awesome rich
gallop Alexander busa zoe quinn thank
you so much for going on
yeah you guys stay there for a minute I
believe something's gonna win a
PlayStation Vita before we get kicked
out of here let's get ready to do so
we're playing star Wally on if it's even
just the tip yeah is your microphone
your might is this room fight talk
really loudly whoa mature there we go
there we go ah first person from this
area to put up two hands gets to play it
was you he beat you had your hand up
first but he went to first I was so
close is that when see all right and
over here hold up exactly three fingers
this guy right here okay Oh the game is
star wall just the tip in the year 20xx
narwhals have ascended into space faring
life-forms whose only goal is to jab
each other in the hearts with their
pointy tusks we're gonna play for one
minute with no spam over here below my
people who i have chosen go why is this
button have you guys played star wall
yeah it's a I think it's edit a UK i'm
pretty sure say on that handle it's
basically a multiplayer game where
you're all narwhals and you have to stop
the narwhal in Narwhal hard it's pretty
good pick different colors put something
on your head tell me what your name is
my name's Tim Tim vs Doug Doug Doug and
Tim Tim Brando applause Doggett it all
right
the jewel for the PlayStation Vita
begins now press the a button please
ever and lost the tip all that is
required is the tip to pierce the hearts
the buttons are as follows a is to flap
your tail use the ANA left analog stick
to point yourself in a different guy
you've got our first hit of the round
there's 44 seconds left one nil is the
score these graceful athletes are
tomorrow what a face from dog Tim and
Doug here locked in a death struggle for
a PlayStation Vita the hard expose
that's amateur mistake you can't be that
careless with your heart we've got 12 20
lemons equalized we're counting down to
15
gets it on the wrong side and then nine
hey ladies got three it's too we're
counting on one and here he is folks
let's go luck that PETA show go go go go
go go go your runner-up winner of the
guy who almost got to win the VA
you